all right joining us now warm welcome to
Tulsi gabbard Fox News contributor
[Applause]
you could read that and see that from
there if you're better than I am still
okay all right so Democrats don't want
to run Republicans absolutely don't want
them to run although maybe we do no no
wait let's think about it he is so he
doesn't know it's Monday I think I'll
I'd rather take my chances with him do
you think he is capable of dealing with
China and Russia and Iran do you think
he's capable of turning this economy
around
there are so many issues here uh you've
mentioned a couple of them there are
many many more we could go down the list
of his indefensible record that he's had
as president one of the things though is
that the American people need to be able
to examine these issues what's the
traditional way that we normally do that
through a debate right well the DNC just
announced we're not going to have any
presidential primary debates and so you
know for me as a presidential candidate
back in 2020 they were rigging the
system back then they were just more
subtle about it tossing softball
questions to Kamala Harris and giving
people more time but but now they are so
arrogant and so disrespectful to the
American people and voters they're just
saying nope we're not going to allow any
debates we're not going to put his
record in front of the American people
we're not going to give people any
choice other than Joe Biden and so my
appeal to Democrats and to American
voters if you are even thinking of
voting for for uh
I was about to say Donald Trump if
you're even thinking about voting so
you're president Trump is that what
you're saying if people are thinking
about voting for President Biden they
really need to ask themselves if they
want to support a candidate that is has
so much disdain and disrespect for the
American people his agenda is failing
and I don't think he's up to the job now
I'll I'll make a comparison I don't
think age is the issue Bernie Sanders is
old but he is sharp as attack yeah now I
sat with Donald Trump for well over an
hour we ran a full hour and then we had
another segment the next night another
one the next night and never stop we and
he can talk forever on any subject you
throw at him and not stop so it's not
about age it's about the person it's not
and and here's this is what I think the
Democratic machine uh their play is for
them to be able to stay in power they
need Joe Biden to run for re-election
get re-elected so that when he gets to
that point where he cannot function
which will likely happen sooner than
later they will then install their
puppet their chosen one Kamala Harris to
become the unelected president United
States I don't and then she runs and
then she runs again in 2028 with the
power of the incumbency behind her they
want someone that they can control and
you think they can control Kamala Harris
Why do you believe that I have no doubt
about it you look at how she uh carries
herself you look at her inability to
perform coherent sentences
um
The Mystery of the ages can you explain
the uncontrollable giggling
yes I can actually to me it shows
nervousness anxiety and fear wow that's
actually great analysis
I definitely don't want you analyzing me
because that was dead
Gavin Newsom I believe has a chance to
win the nomination and I think in the
back of his mind I may be wrong is
thinking of running would he have a
chance against Joe Biden
the Democrats seem to be lining up
behind Joe Biden for the reasons that
I've stated but don't they see what we
see don't they see that he's incoherent
don't they see the cognitive decline
again the numbers seem to show that
right wouldn't they be open to
if you stayed a Democrat you would have
a hard time because you're not going to
go along with the climate alarmist
religious culture well I'm not going to
go along with the Litany of insane
issues and agenda the so-called woke
agenda the Democrats are pushing and I
think more and more people are seeing
that insanity and are very concerned
about it and rightly so this is why this
this Democratic process really needs to
play out and it's why the DNC and the
Democrats are doing everything they can
to stop it we love having you in New
York thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else